Traduttore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Chi di voi è insegnante?
Chi di voi è genitore?
Chi di voi, invece,
si sente educatore o mentore?
È proprio vero: tutti siamo educatori!
Tutti siamo mentori!
Tutti abbiamo delle responsabilità
nei confronti degli studenti,
nei confronti dei figli,
nei confronti dei collaboratori.
Che sfida!
La sfida è proprio quella di educare,
da e-ducere, tirar fuori il meglio
dalle persone che in un qualche modo
la vita ci ha affidato.
E io, nella mia attività di educatore,
ho sempre cercato di portare le persone
a quello che sarebbero potute essere,
partendo dalle situazioni
di competenze e attitudini iniziali.
Mi ha sempre guidato
questa frase di Goethe:
"Trattate un essere umano
per quello che è,
e rimarrà quello che è.
Trattate un essere umano
per quello che può e deve essere,
e diventerà quello che può
e deve essere."
E trattare una persona
per quello che può e deve diventare,
è molto importante
perché, in un mercato del lavoro
che è in rapida evoluzione,
noi dobbiamo garantire
che possano prosperare.
Perché questi scenari da Gig Economy,
di cui si è detto
molto bene in precedenza,
ci fanno dire che coloro che nascono oggi
molto probabilmente faranno un lavoro
che oggi non è stato ancora inventato.
E allora, come facciamo noi
a creare il giusto mindset?
Io cercherò di rispondere
a questa domanda:
è innato, oppure lo si può imparare?
Ma prima ancora diamo una risposta
a queste domande:
Quali sono le abilità essenziali
che all'interno di un'organizzazione
sono richieste?
Ringrazio Seth Godin
perché le ha suddivise
in abilità professionali
e abilità personali.
Le abilità professionali
sono facili da identificare.
Come in questo caso:
questo sito, creato da Robby Leonardi,
mostra chiaramente che Robby Leonardi
è capace di programmare
perché presenta il proprio CV
come se fosse un videogioco.
Quindi, i selezionatori,
in fase di selezione,
hanno facilità ad identificare
le capacità di questa persona.
Inoltre, le abilità professionali
sono anche facili da misurare.
Coloro che in questa sala hanno
la mia età, sono della mia generazione,
sicuramente si ricordano
delle dattilografe
che venivano misurate
sulla base delle battute al minuto.
Così come, non so se vi ricordate,
quei loschi figuri che giravano
all'interno dei reparti,
chiamati "Funzione Tempi e Metodi",
e che, con il cronometro in mano,
misuravano la produttività delle persone.
Invece, le abilità personali,
sono un po' più di difficile misurazione.
Pensate per esempio alla difficoltà
nel misurare le responsabilità,
nel misurare la capacità
di assumersi rischi, di lavorare in team.
Eppure, all'interno di un'organizzazione,
se una persona, pur avendo
delle buone capacità professionali,
viene colto nel mentre ruba dalla cassa,
viene immediatamente allontanato.
Mentre una persona, invece,
che è disfattista,
che rema contro l'organizzazione -
ecco, questa persona è più
di difficile allontanamento.
E allora, pensiamo un attimo
e vediamo queste nuove attività.
[Video]
Intervistatore: Qual è la tua debolezza?
Sono testardo. Testardo.
Testardo, credo.
intervistatore: Dammi
un motivo per assumerti.
Lo sport è la mia passione.
Il football è la mia passione.
Mi piace molto il football.
(Tutti i colloqui di lavoro sono identici)
(Stesse domande standard,
stesse risposte standard)
(Come trovare il giusto talento
per uno stage tra 1734 candidati?
(Test 3: L'uscita)
Intervistatore: Appassionato
o freddo calcolatore?
Direi freddo calcolatore perché...
Intervistatore: Risposta sbagliata.
Fuoco e passione...
Lei ha detto che gli altri
sono bloccati dalla mente
Intervistatore: Credi che io lo sia ora?
No.
(suono di allarme)
Dobbiamo andare.
Simon, Mr Ross, per favore.
Forza, dobbiamo uscire.
Potete aiutarci, per favore?
Potete aiutarci?
Forza, dai!
(Guy Lutchting hai ottenuto il lavoro)
Ogni riferimento all'attualità
è puramente casuale, ovviamente.
(Risate)
Guy Lutching ha ottenuto il lavoro perché
ha dimostrato delle abilità personali.
I selezionatori stanno cambiando
il loro approccio
nei confronti di questa
tipologia di selezione.
Ora, cerchiamo di capire ulteriormente
come le abilità professionali
possano essere insegnate.
È facile rispondere,
perché nessuno nasce
con delle competenze di costruire ponti,
Oppure delle competenze
per tenere la contabilità.
Però le abilità personali, invece,
possono essere insegnate?
Oppure sono impossibili da insegnare?
Sgombriamo subito il campo:
queste soft skills,
cosiddette abilità leggere,
cosiddette abilità personali,
in realtà sono abilità reali,
sono abilità vive,
sono abilità presenti
tutti i giorni, concrete,
che solo persone, che solo maestri veri,
maestri competenti, possono insegnare.
[Solo] maestri profondi possono insegnare.
Possono insegnare queste abilità reali,
cioè la capacità di essere recettivi
ai trasferimenti delle competenze
che l'organizzazione decide di trasferire,
in modo carismatico li trasferiscono poi
agli altri collaboratori
perché sono orientati ai risultati.
E sanno motivare, oltre che essere
motivati a loro volta,
in modo paziente e capace di ascoltare.
Una delle modalità attraverso le quali
è possibile insegnare le abilità reali,
è proprio l'introduzione
dell'imprenditorialità nella scuola.
Se questo ragazzo
fosse stato in una scuola
che avesse inserito nella propria
attività l'imprenditorialità,
sicuramente non avrebbe avuto tarpate
le ali della sua intraprendenza
e non avrebbe nemmeno
preso questa multa.
Nella mia esperienza,
il 20% dei miei studenti
esercita un'attività
imprenditoriale in proprio.
Contro una media nazionale
che è intorno al 2-3%.
Creando valore per la comunità,
avendo creato 800 posti di lavoro.
Perché? Perchè si instillano
nei ragazzi, negli studenti
queste qualità, queste abilità
tipiche dell'imprenditore.
Di poter individuare i bisogni,
di poter rispondere a questi bisogni
creando prodotti e servizi,
di saper lavorare in team,
di saper avere questo approccio,
questa mentalità da imprenditore,
per individuare punti di forza
e punti di debolezza.
E i punti di debolezza comportano poi,
come fa tipicamente l'imprenditore,
la capacità di trovare le conoscenze
per prendere le decisioni.
Ma abilità professionali
e abilità reali non bastano.
Per generare talenti, bisogna
ulteriormente, io dico,
stimare il lavoro proprio
in primo luogo, e il lavoro degli altri.
Pensate che bello
se, all'interno della scuola,
i tre stakeholder principali,
studenti, genitori e docenti
collaborassero fra di loro
e si stimassero a vicenda.
Pensate con quale gratitudine
gli studenti guarderebbero i docenti
se respirassero in casa la fiducia
nel lavoro che viene
sviluppato dai docenti.
E poi,
cambiamo la cultura del fallimento,
dell'errore, dello sbaglio,
come se fosse negativo.
Dobbiamo vederli in modo positivo:
dobbiamo cambiare questa mentalità.
Perché?
Perché l'errore,
il fallimento, lo sbaglio,
sono punti di ripartenza
e forti dell'esperienza di quello
che è successo precedentemente.
Tanto è vero che nel mondo anglosassone,
in particolare in quello americano,
vengono inseriti nei CV,
nei curriculum vitae,
e le persone vengono valutate
positivamente dai selezionatori.
Infine, tutto quello
che abbiamo detto prima:
sbaglio, fallimento, errore,
non definisca mai la persona.
E questo ce lo insegna Gesù Cristo,
tra l'altro ben riportato
in questo capolavoro del Caravaggio,
"La vocazione di San Matteo",
dove indica Matteo e lo chiama a sé,
indipendentemente dal peccato
che ha commesso.
E noi dobbiamo fare la stessa cosa
nei confronti di tutti coloro
che la vita ci ha affidato.
Noi non dobbiamo giudicarli per l'errore,
per lo sbaglio, per il fallimento.
Ma dobbiamo attrarli a noi.
Infine, consentitemi di dire
che "it's time to",
è il tempo di far desiderare le persone,
di far sentire la nostalgia,
la mancanza dello spazio siderale,
la mancanza delle stelle,
perché solo in questo modo
noi possiamo creare persone vere,
possiamo valorizzare la persona.
Tutti, o almeno quasi tutti,
ci siamo definiti all'inizio educatori.
Allora concludo dicendo:
qualsiasi sia la questione,
qualsiasi sia il problema,
l'educazione è la soluzione.
Grazie.
(Applausi)